السماوات والارض
[Silence]
الله اني اسالك علما نافع ع رزقا طيبا
وملا وتقبلا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد
لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام على
رسوله الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى
في كتاب رياض الصالحين
في باب الصبر وعن ابي مالك الحارث بن عاصم
الاشعري رضي الله عنه
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
رياض الصالحين
الحافظ النبوي رحمه
‏inحين
chapter
to breath and merit and
الحارث ابن عاصم الاشعري
رضي الله عنه ابو مالك الاشعري
ابو مالك الاشعري
حديث
الحارث بن عاصم رضي الله عنه
ابو مالك الاشعري
ابو موسى الاشعري
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الطهور شطر الايمان
الله صلى الله عليه
‏fafication
this is
capacity a literal capacity
also in a spirit capacity
in a literal physical capacity
meaning
وضوء
صلاه
صلاه الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلاه ايمان ان قران وما كان الله ليضيع
ايمانكم
‏and
a spirit standpo
of
meaning ne
to negate something
is half of faith we look at the epidemy
of
which is the statement لا اله الا الله
لا اله الا الله
النفي والاثبات
لا
لا اله الا
اللهcept
‏haveillar
missing
not enter into
ifill
we only have affiration
we have the worship of along with other
and if we have the second missing ‏and
only affirming the first part which is
negation اله
none is rightfully worshiped then we
have the worship of no one of non
these are two pillars so we see that
half ofان
is what
is negation and this is a general
principle that the scholars of islam
refer to
التطهير قبل الاثبات او يقولون
التخليه
قبل التحليه
قبل التحليه هذه قاعده شرعيه
عظيمه
جليله
التخليه
قبل التحليه
‏That is that negation
purification
comes before adornment and
beautification
right so for instance a person wishes to
wishes to adorn himself first they bathe
first they remove any filth then the
adornment comes. ‏If the adornment comes
on top of the filth,
what happens now? Now we have
a filthy
body that has
soخليه
قبل التحليه تجدها في القران كثيرا
ليس كمثله شيء
وهو السميع البصير
اللهing
all
first
exped
‏and
devoid of any incorrect belief then the
correct belief comes into the heart
for everything you know then learn this
is how it work however if a person tries
to mi that which is correct and that
which is incorrect together in the same
heart it will begin
الطهور شطر الايمان
والحمد لله تملا الميزان
ان الحمد لله
وسبحان الله والحمد لله تملان او تملا ما
بين السماوات والارض
سبحان الله الحمد لله
والصلاه نور
والصدقه برهان
والصبر ضياء
والقران حجه لك اوك
قران
كل الناس يغدو
فبائع نفسه فمعتقها
[Silence]
‏into
servitation
byl
we nar
will
in upcall
to takeer
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا